بينما رفعت بريطانيا مستوى التهديد لديها
من هجمات ارهابيه محتمله الى شديد تقول
الولايات المتحده انها تعمل على تعقب
المقاتلين الاجانب الذين يسافرون من والى
سوريا كما انها تعزز امن الطيران في
الخارج مع الرحالات المباشره الى امريكا
منذ هذا الصيف على المسافرين من مطارات
الشرق الاوسط واوروبا المتجهين الى امريكا
اثبات ان جميع الاجهزه الالكترونيه التي
بحوزتهم ليست موادا متفجره وتقول اجهزه
الاستخبارات ان الارهابيين قد يطورون
قنابل متقدمه يمكنها المرور عبر اجهزه فحص
المتفجرات بالمطارات اما في المملكه
المتحده فقد بدا اليوم ان هناك علامات
واضحه على قلقهم بشان عوده المقاتلين
الاجانب يقول رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ديفيد كاميرون ان الشرطه تقوم بايقاف
المشتبه بهم من المسافرين والتحفظ على
جوازات سفرهم كما تتبع اجهزه الامن
البريطانيه اجراءات من ضمنها منع مقيمين
اجانب من العوده الى المملكه المتحده
بالاضافه الى حرمان اخرين من المواطنه
ويبدو ان الولايات المتحده تسير في نفس
الاتجاه بعد مقتل امريكيين قاتلوا تحت
رايه تنظيم داعش في سوريا تقول المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه جينيفر بساكي ان
لديهم الحق بالتنسيق مع سلطات انفاذ
القانون لالغاء جوازات السفر عندما يتعلق
الامر بعمل الشخص مع منظمه ارهابيه او
بتشكيل خطر على الامن الامريكي وقد تم
تحديث قائمه منع الطيران وقائمه المراقبه
لانفاذ القانون وتم ارسالهم الى اداره امن
النقل في الوقت الحالي مع مع تطور
التهديدات ولكن يبدو ان هذا النظام ليس
مثاليا نشا منير محمد ابو صلحه في فلوريدا
وسافر الى سوريا ليتدرب كجهات وعاد الى
امريكا ثم تمكن من السفر مجددا واختفى الى
ان فجر نفسه في هجوم انتحاري في سوريا
الله اكبر وقد يشهد ال 14 مليون مسافر
امريكي عمليات امن مشدده امريكا لم تعد
تستخدم نظام الالوان لتقييم اي تهديد
ارهابي محتمل فقد توقف استخدام عام 2011
لكونه مربكا وغير فعالا النظام المستخدم
حاليا ينشر التنبيهات على موقع دي اتش اس
ويرسله الى الصحافه ووسائل الاعلام
الاجتماعيه عند وجود تهديد
شديد